tu as que vous allez vous espérer
reprendre un dialogue fécond avec lui
alors que vous étiez l'interlocuteur
privilégié du précédent quinquennat ça
n'est plus le sert à ça c'est une
formule le ce qui est sure il le sait le
lendemain de son élection je lui ai fait
une lettre ouverte au président la
république en disant partager le pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est clair que ce
gouvernement il est à la croisée des
chemins et cet exécutif il a croisée des
chemins
est ce que dans cette volonté de
transformation du pays qu'on peut pas
lui signé il veut faire en concertant en
négociant en discutant avec les corps
intermédiaires mais pas simplement les
organisations syndicales les électeurs à
pronal il affecte la zone où est ce
qu'il veut faire sans s'il veut faire
sens je le dis ça court à l'échec
oui ça va rester comme chez gagnaire ce
matin le délégué dans marche il a dit
qu'il y avait un pouvoir politique est
certes le dialogue social il a dit
christophe castaner mais il ya également
un pouvoir politique qui a été élu et
qui a toute légitimité pour changer les
choses oui mais vous savez donc ça me
rend de la route et l italie on a eu un
premier ministre un moment donné en
italie qui monsieur renzi justement j'en
parlais qui a dit j'arrive et vous allez
voir ça va transformer je fais mon job
act je veux faire tout un tas de réforme
une par mois et vous allez voir par la
seule volonté politique par ma
légitimité politique j'ai le faire il
s'est cassé la figure
excusez moi de vous dire il s'est cassé
la figure parce qu'il n'ya pas de
transformation de la société
si on n'emmène pas les corps
intermédiaires avec si on on entraîne
pas derrière et qui qui a cette capacité
là ce sont les seuls corps
intermédiaires donc moi j'entends cette
légitimité politique
là des mots clés je crois qu'il ya aussi
l'exercice de la démocratie sociale et
c'est pas une concurrence
c'est une imbrication des deux et je le
dis il faut écouter les corps
intermédiaires money time en a marre on
c'est vrai dans l'agriculture alors par
les boulistes
les grecs votaient avec les responsables
agricoles partout on a le sentiment
qu'il ya une forme de défiance à l'égard
des corps intermédiaires et bien si
cette défiance devait était un mode de
gouvernement
je le dis ça ira à l'échec mais vous lui
dit on lui dit au président de la bgd me
dis qu'on lui dit angelica l'attention
de survie dit nous sommes le gage de
votre réussite
non nous sommes surtout le gage que d'un
pays ne sombre pas dans ses vieux démons
et neurones
n'oublions pas que ce qui a fait les
sandisk arrêter les résultats qui ont
été les résultats excusez-moi l'air
ulta de l'élection présidentielle ça n'a
pas disparu ce qu'a fait le terreau que
le front national soit au second tour
d'élection présidentielle
cela n'a pas disparu de notre pays et si
on veut pas que ça ressurgissent on n'a
pas de nom n'a pas intérêt à ce que ça
se plante
je suis clair là dessus non mais ça peut
pas réussir si on fait pas de politique
sociale assumer et si on fait sans décor
en terme